really quick mm a minute well switch
topics this is Mark Hunt statement cuz
I've to help you know that Brock Lesnar
tested positive of course just look at
his [ __ ] body duh
this was an official statement he put on
ma our Mark Hunt here's part of it
well this [ __ ] white piece of [ __ ]
sticking needles in his ass and say oh
he's gonna take all of us all the way to
the [ __ ] Bank let's give him [ __ ]
millions of dollars and not worry about
his [ __ ] you know what [ __ ] that
and [ __ ] your [ __ ] company look at that
for a contract you consume me on that
[ __ ] now he's Dana White that
was today no I good for him good for him
because they they didn't allow John
Jones to fight in that 200 card they
didn't allow Conor McGregor to fight
because he missed a press conference but
they allow a juiced out Brock Lesnar who
they gave a window of exemption to not
even test him very tight one yeah right
and and and you you allow him to take
the [ __ ] big bag of cash in the
meantime Mark Hunt who's risked his life
against a [ __ ] behemoth man goes home
with no [ __ ] cash you know what I
mean yeah like it's it's absurd it's
absurd that company is so inconsistent
and so mob like that it's laughable I
think that they know white the Ender
they sold the collection four billion
richer not only do I own Astana wasn't I
want to go to UFC now I retract my
statement to Mark Hunt don't target that
you know you're doing a great job for
the thing what he did some area Kalani I
can you know what so what do you think
about Mark Hunt saying that he's gonna
leave he wants to leave us you're not
gonna leave no I think that he should
wait it out because I think that a
fighters union is on its way we're gonna
fight if I Bors in New Zealand I mean
[ __ ] throw you know I mean for a
little a little hula dresses dancing on
the beach no get your [ __ ] together mark
shut the [ __ ] up you know he's green a
white side I love them I love them
because Joe Romo is about to leave and
they need a new commentator really she
was gonna leave yeah he said he would
leave what if the UFC ever got bought
out
and if I can happen I just I here's what
I here's one I want to say what they did
the Holly Holm oh my lord
Holly Holm right is it's done now for
her it is it's done she lost two in a
row yeah it's done yeah because like she
number one didn't didn't defend her belt
we should took it right I didn't defend
her either yeah she's done I think me
she's done you know I think Holly's done
and it's like they're just throwing
these girls out there and they're using
them up and I think that they should
have held on Holly Holm should just been
champion and waited for Ronda to come
back being out if I have that big money
fight but she gets [ __ ] no I don't
believe that I think that you know she
got [ __ ] yeah but I
she's a competitive woman she wants to
take a fight every three months and I
don't think there's anything wrong with
her taking you know girls like bullet or
who's the last one she fought
yeah Misha she lost to meet you yeah
it's like those are the girls in the top
five so why wouldn't they you know yeah
but but but now it's like when is she
gonna fight next who's she gonna fight
exactly she's gonna be on some sort of
[ __ ] B card you know I mean in some
obscure night and Fox night you don't
think she still has the whole like I
beat Ronda Rousey's no I don't because I
think that first of all is Ronda Rousey
gonna fight Holly Holm or Nunez true
that's the first fight that that Ron is
gonna get I think Nunez who's gonna get
bullet next probably and I think that
Nunez is gonna be bullet I love Nunez
she's great and no one's talking about
how good Nunez is because of the fact
that she you know Brazilian or no
scissors some other elements she
scissors know what is the other element
nothing
I did everything Bobby she's not pretty
that's what I'm saying that's exactly
different elements no I just think that
she is somebody that has an accent she
does unholy activities in the bed with
other women and that way has nothing to
do with me I love it I support
the LGBT yeah and I believe that uh
she's not a marketable face right well
she's also not speaks English but she's
not a Polly Hall preacher's daughter All
American you know all those things play
into a narrative a storyline a new
Tania's is you know Brazilian okay but
the question is Brazilian do you want to
just see good fights or do you want a
narrative like no I'm saying I love
doing yes no what I'm saying is you know
if we're always talking about
marketability that's gonna you know
we're not you're not prioritizing good
fights you're prioritizing the narrative
you know so you're operating like a
business rather than a real sport well
it's for me it's like it is a business
and I know you're the one that taught me
about Makana McGregor all right I wasn't
I was at that point of view before Conor
McGregor I was like it should be based
on my yeah but it's not it's an
entertainment sport and Conor McGregor
you know is it entertainer and he master
has revitalized that sport I think Jon
Jones is an entertainer I think that the
stuff that he does running over a
pregnant lady and although part of the
narrative is a part of the narrative and
it makes it like exciting and weird you
know I think guys like Luke Rockhold
who's like just this guy I loved on
bottom row because really he's just like
a good-looking white dude that person
you know he's eight boards and it's not
really doesn't fit into any kind of
thing you know he's a nice guy
Cormier - they're all nice guys that
whole camp actually okay came to Alaska
nice guys are all friends and also it's
a white guy a black guy in a Mexican I
don't like it I don't like it but I
think Connor I think what you wanna
young Jake Jake did for that Claudia
Claudia filos but yeah what she was
doing what she was learned it from the
connor blueprint
yeah I think that it's good to be both
to understand the business and to be the
best fighter so if you're in the top
five come up with a personality come up
with an alter ego or come up with a
great story for yourself because that's
just gonna make you this isn't a big
money-making sport so it's like get it
while you can while your name is hots if
I was Holly Holm I would have probably
ran over a pregnant lady too yeah I
think Josie although right yeah is now
beginning he's starting
he's starting he grew a mustache no I'm
not be kidding you it was funny though
oh you're laughing he's trying to be a
villain now I he looks a little like
Moriarty old-timey like like Sherlock
Holmes you villain he grew a moustache
he's saying he's trying to speak English
now which is weird which is weird
and he said calling out Conor McGregor
when Conor burgers don't even fighting
invited him in his division you know so
now like Josie Aldo looks like a crazy
person
yeah in a man and he's like he's in the
movie you know they're making about
movie they were almost done with the
movie do you know that about him oh yeah
no you know they in Brazil I mean if
they had an actor that played him and
they were shooting in the movie and when
he lost to Conor McGregor they stopped
production yeah which only made him
crazier probably yeah and now he
probably just talked to himself in a
mirror and I he's turning into a [ __ ]
psychopath psychopath and we like what
we were [ __ ] love it and what we saw
him against Frankie Edgar was a
different kind of fighter I believe you
know I love maybe he looks so good
you look really disgusting what that one
you blew a piece of food into the mic
and you just pluck
[Music]